hello thank you for the opportunity to
be the plenary speaker at orwh's 30th
anniversary
it's a great honor for me today to
present to you
on women's mental health across the
lifespan
i'd like to disclose that i've been a
consultant for stellis pfizer abvie and
bell kim
however all of my research for the past
25 years has been supported by the
national institutes of health
as well as by the illinois department of
public health
today in my talk i would like to talk
about sex and gender differences in
women's mental health
with a particular focus at particular
milestones in a woman's life
so today we'll be talking about
childhood
puberty
college
pregnancy adulthood
menopause and the later years
recognizing that a lifespan perspective
is very important
this slide illustrates the lifetime
prevalence of mental health disorders by
sex what we can see is that women have a
higher prevalence of anxiety disorders
and mood disorders compared to men
whereas men have a higher prevalence of
impulse disorders and substance use
disorders
why do we care about women's mental
health
a 2020 publication in the lancet
highlighted findings from the world
health organization reporting that in
2019 depressive disorders and anxiety
disorders were among the top 10 leading
causes of disability worldwide
this was true for females but not for
males
and in 2019
21.8
of american women who were age 20 or
older had depression based on a survey
using the patient health questionnaire 8
in a given two week period compared to
fifteen percent of men
so these trends worldwide we see as well
in the united states
it's well known that the risk for major
depression in females emerges at puberty
and back in 1993 the gold standard
psychiatric diagnostic interview was
performed on a nationally representative
sample of individuals from the united
states
and in that study it was clear
that females beginning at puberty showed
a higher
prevalence of major depressive disorder
the other peak of the sex difference
emerges in the 40s as shown on this
graph and what you can see is that this
is a time in a woman's life that
corresponds with the perimenopause which
we'll be talking about later
it's also notable that this kind of gold
standard representative study has not
been undertaken until now so there is a
similar study by kessler and gibbons
underway right now which is important
because the socio-demographic
characteristics of our country have
changed dramatically and we need updated
epidemiological data on sex differences
and mental health disorders
now the emergence of the sex difference
that puberty really
focuses us on hormones so we look at
hormonal changes at different periods of
a woman's life
so that at adolescence and puberty the
female increase in ovarian sex steroid
hormones particularly estradiol and
progesterone as well as their
metabolites which become what we call
neuroactive steroids influence brain
circuitry
we see this as well across the menstrual
cycle in studies of premenstrual
dysphoric disorder we see it in the
perinatal or around pregnancy period
and in postpartum depression we also
have a newfound appreciation for the
perimenopause is a window of hormonal
vulnerability to depressive symptoms
anxiety symptoms and psychotic disorders
and these hormone levels change in aging
of course it's not all hormones and it's
not all depression
the lifetime risk of post-traumatic
stress disorder also shows a sex
difference it's two to three times
higher in women than in men
and in part this is due to environmental
exposures so women are exposed to more
high impact trauma such as sexual trauma
compared to men and this occurs at
earlier ages
in work supported by the nih we know
that early life trauma affects the
development of brain circuits underlying
emotional regulation and mood
the lifetime prevalence of generalized
anxiety disorder which is the tendency
to worry
also shows a sex difference
and this is evident across the lifespan
but note here that this is particularly
high in magnitude at the time of the
perimenopause when women in men are
between the ages
are older than age 44.
now
women compared to men have lower rates
of substance use disorder
so these are
data from the substance abuse and mental
health service administration or samhsa
showing males and females substance use
disorders within the last 12 months
and you can see that
the one exception to this women having
lower rates of substance use disorder is
evident at the youngest ages between
ages 12 to 17.
and indeed 2019 trends compared to 2018
trends showed that substance use
disorder is increasing among those aged
12 to 17 years
particularly for females
now why is this important when we take a
lifespan in neurodevelopmental
perspective we know that exposure to
substances illicit substances
early in life during adolescence changes
brain circuits involved in reward and
involved in the pleasure taking of
substances making it very difficult much
more difficult for people to overcome
substance use disorders
when we look at epidemiological change
trends the use of ellipse illicit
substances and marijuana in those 12
years and older increased over the
lifetime for females but not for males
although use in the past year and past
month increased for both sexes
now substance use disorders are more
common in men than women but there are
very important sex differences in
substance use disorders and work funded
by
nida has
demonstrated myriad differences these
include women having higher rates of
co-occurring psychiatric disorders
women are more likely to have a
co-occurring mood disorder 7.5 times
greater or an anxiety disorder 4.2 times
greater nevertheless they're less likely
to receive treatment and they face
particular barriers to treatment
including some of the stigma surrounding
treatment of substance use disorders of
pregnancy
we know that stress induces craving
and work by nida shows differences in
stress-induced dopamine transmission and
women show greater
cravings with stress compared to men
and importantly in women again with a
lifespan perspective the course of
substance use disorder in women is more
strongly linked to childhood trauma
now in women there is a circle
of mental health intersecting with
trauma that sustains and perpetuates
substance use disorders
so that trauma particularly early life
trauma and its related mental health
problems lead to self-medication
of females
and that in turn leads to addiction
which makes women more vulnerable to
victimization which in turn influences
um
or increases their exposure to
additional trauma and mental health
problems so this is a vicious circle for
women and one that
illustrates the importance of the
intersection between
substance use disorders and mental
health disorders with childhood
exposures and continued trauma in women
so let's talk a bit about childhood
work in adverse childhood experiences
shows some sex differences
in that women experience a greater
number of frequent
aces
so women showed more they were more
likely to have more than four aces and
in work done
increasingly across the united states
funded by the national institutes of
health including beautiful work by neil
epperson
shows that these aces have
especially early in life have long
standing influences on brain circuits
and vulnerability to mood disorders
now we think about adverse childhood
events as influencing mental health and
substance use disorder which they do but
it's quite astounding when we look at
the proportion of these disorders that's
explained by these aces so for example
24 of the individual differences
in heavy drinking
are attributable to aces and for
depression 44
of the variance is explained by aces in
other words these adverse childhood
events account for
much of the risk of these disorders
and it's not just mental health
disorders when we look at coronary heart
disease or chd here we see that adverse
childhood events influence
cardiovascular health and this shows the
importance of work by the nhlbi
in mental health as well
childhood sexual abuse is a particularly
important traumatic event to consider in
a lifespan perspective on women's mental
health and there is a very big
difference in
the frequency of sexual abuse between
girls and boys indeed one in four women
and
compared to one in 13 men report having
been sexually abused as a child a
considerable diff
difference
and in women women with a history of
childhood sexual abuse are at in
increased risk of developing
a variety of different mental health
disorders and
they're twice as likely for example
to develop
anxiety disorders major depression
alcohol use disorders drug
dependents and the like and they're also
likely to have more comorbidities more
than one psychiatric disorder so that's
true for any childhood sexual abuse but
exposure to intercourse at during
childhood is predicted particularly
toxic with these odds ratios over five
so that women with this exposure early
in life have a five-fold increased risk
of drug dependence and of having more
than one
disorder so this is an important example
of how we need to focus on childhood
trauma and sexual abuse from a public
health perspective if we want to
optimize women's mental health across
the lifespan
let's talk about puberty now
so we know that the sex difference in
major depressive disorder begins at
puberty and there's work that also shows
sex differences in the trajectories of
depressive symptoms
so for example in girls the age at peak
velocity velocity of depressive symptoms
is younger than that of boys it's
earlier so it starts 13.5 years and
girls compared to 16.4 years in boys
this kind of research informed screening
efforts to suggest that women girls need
to be screened earlier than boys
now work done by monique ernst in the
intramural research program of the
national institutes of health shows that
puberty is accompanied by
measurable changes in brain circuits
that aren't explained by age alone
and these brain circuits underlie
emotional regulation in brain systems
that are implicated in depression and
anxiety
so when we look at these different brain
circuits what we can see at puberty is
that girls brain connectivity that is
the the extent to which one region of
the brain
is
speaking if you will to another area of
the brain that decreases in brain
systems that underlie emotional
regulation whereas boys show an
increased connectivity in those brain
circuits
so how do we know that this is an
important neurobiological difference
well lower connectivity in these brain
circuits in girls was associated with
more severe internalizing problems later
in adolescence so these brain changes
were predictive of symptoms of
depression and anxiety
later in adolescence
and so this kind of work funded by the
nih illustrates how puberty might
amplify the risk for internalizing
symptoms in girls leading again with a
lifespan perspective to an increased
vulnerability to depression and anxiety
okay let's go now to college
we know that nationally there is an
increase in the prevalence of anxiety
depressive disorders and panic attacks
among american college students
and indeed the prevalence uh is
astounding particularly for females with
almost 28
of females uh having an anxiety disorder
and 22 percent of females having a
depressive disorder and panic attacks at
14.8 percent compared to much lower
rates half of that
in males again showing college is an
important inflection point in women's
mental health
we are in the middle of a global
pandemic
students are working from home and it's
interesting that a
new survey research from the healthy
mind students and a very large sample of
individuals from 14 campuses
shows an interesting change
in substance use disorders excuse me
there is an increase in depressive
disorders
but a decrease in suicidal ideation and
a decrease in illicit substance use in
binge drinking however the depressive
symptoms that are increasing during this
pandemic are also associated with
impairment in academic performance again
showing the importance of mental health
disorders to daily functioning in this
case in college students
in the last few years there's been a lot
of appropriate attention to sexual
assault in women with a metoo movement
and the prevalence of
sexual assault in college-age students
is considerably higher in females
compared to males
now
mental health in college is a general
issue but it's important to recognize
that sexual minorities show a higher
prevalence of these disorders and indeed
show a four to five-fold increased risk
in self-harm suicidal thoughts and
suicidal attempts so the most severe
forms of mental health are higher in
sexual minorities
particularly women so this underscores
the importance of targeted efforts at
prevention
let's talk now about pregnancy
when a lot of people think about women's
mental health they think about
postpartum depression there are a lot of
lessons that we've learned by studying
pregnancy i think that can inform our
understanding at other reproductive
milestones in a woman's life
what's particularly important i think is
to consider the perinatal period as a
window of opportunity for the
identification and treatment of a
variety of different mental health
disorders
even if those are not new disorders in
other words even if they did not arise
de novo during pregnancy
women of color and rural women in
particular
have limited access to mental health
services and by implementing mental
health screenings in the perinatal
period we can oftentimes for the first
time begin to screen and identify these
disorders in these disadvantaged
populations
cdc data show that the rates of pregnant
women with a depression diagnosis and
delivery increased by sevenfold
from 2000 to 2015
and subsequent data showed that this
trend actually continues
so
women in the perinatal period show a
very high prevalence of just of
depression
now this is particularly important to
consider for women of color because
compared to white women the odds of
depression prior to delivery were
fivefold higher in black women twofold
higher in latinas and this disparity
persists in the postpartum period the
disparities also continue when we
examine uh delivery of mental health
care now delivery
of mental health care is poor all around
but it's even worse for women of color
why is this important maternal mortality
in the united states is increasing
while it's decreasing in other countries
and we think about uh depression in
particular suicidality is being an
important contributor to maternal
morbidity
indeed a very recent study
in jama psychiatry showed a
considerable increase in suicidal
ideation
and in self-harm
over the last decade this was
particularly true for young women and
women of color as well as women with
psychiatric comorbidities including
anxiety depression and comorbid
psychosis so
maternal mortality in the united states
is an important consideration in women's
mental health
small efforts efforts at simply
screening women during the perinatal
period pay off so in absolute terms just
the implementation of mental health
screenings in the perinatal period
reduces depression prevalence by two to
nine percent and in terms of women with
a psychiatric diagnosis the screening
can reduce remission 10 to 34
in absolute terms so the importance of
screening can't be underestimated
now
science has advanced our understanding
of how to better detect
psychiatric diagnoses in women so one
approach is computerized adaptive
diagnostics
here i highlight the work of robert
gibbons a colleague from the university
of chicago who is implementing a new
approach to the the identification of
mental health disorders essentially this
is a technology based approach that
draws items in a screener
from a very deep item bank
and tailors the screening to each woman
depending upon her response to the
previous question
we have implemented this work in our own
perinatal research study and i'd like to
show you some initial data to illustrate
to you the importance of screening as
well as the importance of screening for
more than one psychiatric diagnosis in
the perinatal period
so in our clinic which serves women of
color living in chicago
we find that
21
of women actually screen positive for
major depressive disorder at some point
during pregnancy or their very early
postpartum period
so among the women with depression um
you can see that the majority had only
major depressive disorder but look at
the percentage of women who had a
comorbid diagnosis six percent of women
for example had
generalized anxiety disorder post
traumatic stress disorder and substance
use disorder again illustrating
comorbidities as a very important
consideration and also illustrating the
value of techniques like computerized
adaptive diagnostics for efficiently
quickly and sensitively detecting these
different
mental health disorders in the clinic
setting
there are also novel approaches to
treatment delivery here i highlight the
work of mike o'hara and jenna duffy with
their sunny side an evidence-based
cognitive behavior therapy approach that
can be delivered on the internet free of
charged without stigma of a clinic visit
without needing to get a babysitter and
it's been shown to prevent perinatal
depression
in the population so technological
advances in screening and in the
treatment of
psychiatric diagnose diagnoses are very
important and evidence shows many of
these studies supported by the nih that
these online treatments are as effective
as brief face-to-face
treatments and of course it's not enough
to use cognitive behavior therapy some
women need pharmacological treatment and
one of the great successes over the past
decade was the development of roxanne
alone an aloe pregnant
aloe pregnant alone based treatment that
is a metabolite of progesterone
for postpartum depression and this has
been shown to very quickly and
effectively treat postpartum depression
and it's now available
in pill form which is also shown great
of effectiveness so what this shows us
is that understanding the
neurobiological underpinnings that is
the hormonal neuroactive steroid
underpinnings of mental health disorders
at critical times like the perinatal
period can inform novel treatments for
mental health disorders
it's important to treat mental health
disorders in pregnancy not just for mom
but also for her offspring this is
neuro-imaging work functional magnetic
resonance work that's been done in
six-month-old children of moms either
with or without perinatal depression and
what they showed is that six months of
age in these offspring you could detect
differences in the emotional regulation
circuitry showing the importance again
of treating
antenatal mood disorders in women to
benefit the offspring
let's move now to adulthood
there's been a lot of talk about
harassment and discrimination in the
workplace
and this is very common
but one thing i'd like to point out is
the intersectionality of this experience
so that women of mixed race or ethnicity
experience the highest levels of this
exposure overall
in this exposure harassment and
discrimination in turn leads to
increases in problem drinking and mental
health disorders
particularly among women
work by my good colleague rebecca
thurston at the university of pittsburgh
has shown the importance of these
exposures not to mental health
specifically but rather to physical
health
so that there was a twofold higher odds
of women having hypertension if they had
high levels of harassment in their daily
life
one of the signature programs of the
office of research on women's health is
the building interdisciplinary research
careers in women's health a birch k-12
program which funds
young investigators to pursue
studies of women's health or sex and
gender-based
medicine in health
our birch colleagues uh and my co-pi of
the uic bridge irene irena bahimshi
completed a survey of over
500 faculty at our own institution to
look at work life and stress before and
after covid and what you can see here
is that there's high levels of stress
but women carrying more of it it's
impacted their scholarly productivity
their teaching their advising their
committee responsibilities
and their own personal health
so work stress
is an important consideration menopause
is also important now the perimenopause
is a window of vulnerability for
depression
and for
subclinical depressive symptoms
and we can see here in work by joyce
bromberger and the study of women's
health across the nation a doubling at
any point in time of the prevalence of
peri of depression in the perimenopause
and post-menopause compared to the
pre-menopause
most women who experience depression at
this time in life are women with a
history of depression prior to the
menopause and so this represents a
recurrence of their depressive disorder
but it's not just depression
an excellent article published in the
popular press by lisa miller
it published in new york magazine
highlighted the importance of psychotic
disorders in women at the time of the
menopause and epidemiological studies
show a second increase in the
prevalence of these disorders or the
risk of these disorders at the menopause
so we need to take our lens beyond just
depression and look at other psychiatric
diagnoses
hormonal contributions are important
there's proof of concept for example
that the use of estrogen can dampen
psychotic symptoms in women at this time
but it's not just the hormonal changes
at menopause it's a variety of things
it's biological factors health related
factors and psychosocial factors that
affect a woman's mental health and then
we have the later years in a woman's
life
this is a gender difference caregiving
typically falls to women two-thirds of
caregivers are women
particularly in the field of dementia so
wives take care of their husbands with
dementia and daughters do the same and
when women are caregivers they spend
more time caregiving than men
and these women who provide this
caregiving request more mental health
services
and they are not widely available
the irony is that depression is
associated with a 36 increased risk of
cognitive decline in women so women
serve as caregivers for their husbands
in
with alzheimer's disease and
nevertheless the mental health sequelae
of that experience contributes to their
own risk for cognitive disorders
so it's important to recognize this
intersection between mental health and
cognitive health
so today we've done a survey of women's
mental health across the lifespan we've
talked about childhood puberty college
pregnancy
adulthood menopause in the later years
taking a lifespan
perspective and i hope this has
illustrated the importance and the
success of the work
that's being done at the nih in this
important question and how it intersects
with other nih institutes including the
national institute on
drug abuse and
the nih lbi
i'm indebted to my very good colleagues
for their collaboration in my work over
the last 30 years
and i also want to
personally congratulate dr clayton
and dr vivian pinn on the 30th
anniversary of the office of research on
women's health in a special thing to
reach thanks to regine de tao for
inviting me to come here it's been a
great honor thank you